calm shores
a deceiving snapshot of the uk's refugee
crisis
over 10 000 have crossed this year among
them the first to be sent to rwanda next
week after the high court denied an
injunction to block their flight
devastated and desperate um but if any
of them are able to see their site you
know i guess our message would be that
we are not going to stop fighting we
will be strongly considering our next
steps and we continue to believe as
strongly as we did this morning this is
an unlawful policy causing great harm
and we'll continue to challenge it this
is a brutal policy against people who
are already traumatized i can tell you
that we've seen about a hundred of them
already and simply on the knowledge that
they might be deported it others further
trauma
the plan is to send asylum seekers to
accommodation like this in rwanda where
their case will be heard
campaigners argued in court it's
unlawful and safe and unfair
the government's legal team said the new
immigration policy is in the public
interest to deter dangerous and illegal
journeys
the government's rwanda scheme is is a
chaotic diversion not thought through
scheme which isn't going to solve the
problems of course we don't want people
making that danger of crossing of course
we want to clamp down on the people
smugglers the way to do that is to have
a proper plan with the french
authorities and a proper plan for
upstream operations to intercept these
groups before they even arrive on the
north coast of france
in a statement the home secretary said
people will continue to try and prevent
their relocation through legal
challenges and last minute claims but we
will not be deterred in breaking the
deadly people smuggling trade and
ultimately saving lives
the home office know though that this
wasn't their last legal battle but they
are committed politically to pursuing
this policy to be seen to be tough on
immigration post-brexit they insist it
is lawful and complies with their
international obligations
and in dungeness on the front line of
illegal migration there's some support
if they're estimating 100 000 by
the end of the year
then we can't just sit back and do
nothing something definitely needs to
happen but whether it's the right move i
don't know i think it should be done
before they come across
an appeal will likely be heard on monday
another 11th hour attempt to stop the
rwanda flight and not the last all this
is just the start
adele robinson sky news at the high
court